do you ever research each other when you
haven't met as actors yeah you know I
googled Carl but there's just not a lot
out there on the internet about know
you're clean it's only pretty difficult
yeah I already you know how to little
like shrine obtained in my room so I
guess we knew everything about his
writings visually as a director you must
be thinking forward all the time it's
funny how the imagination nourish
himself it's like a muscle being a kid I
loved Fifth Element I love Lee before
moving so much it's a complete honor I
can't breathe and still believe I'm
living my dream for a director you
fighting with two things the experience
and the freshness okay when you start
you have no experience and 100% of
freshness and then you get older and you
know expressly okay and the land I made
valayan exactly where I still have this
freshness a bit and when you watch the
movie which seems you see in you're like
well I'm a bad I had so much fun doing
that scene in real life like again and
again and again again and again and
again
it was just like pretty yeah
exhilarating aliens do they exist
there's 100 million billion stars in the
universe if we think we're alone we're
crazy
okay well I'm an alien and I'm right
here so yes they do exist
[Music]